The Joe Rogan experience.
Is there any evidence that there was other species of human beings that existed
in the Americas?
Like we're finding in Russia and,
uh,
there's,
many of them that are being discovered all over the world now,
these subspecies of human beings.
Yeah.
Um,
this is,
uh,
an issue that I go into in,
in America before.
And what first drew me into it was Dennis over K in Siberia.
I think everybody's heard of the neanderthals.
And these days,
I think everybody's head of the dentist's as well.
A lot of people have a lot of,
well,
I guess a lot of people haven't,
but,
but first of all,
let's take the neanderthals.
For a long time,
it was held that the neanderthals were stupid,
primitive subhumans shambling lacking symbolism.
Turns out that that's not true at all.
The latest scientific evidence on the neanderthals is that they were symbolic
creatures.
That they did do art,
that they were in every sense human,
and they were in every sense human because anatomically modern humans interbred
with neanderthals,
you can't interbreed with another species.
They,
they clearly were,
uh,
human human beings,
but they looked rather different from us.
And that's why certain populations in the world today still have three to 5% of
Neanderthal DNA.
Then in Russia,
in Dennis over cave,
they find a single pinky bone from a little finger.
And,
uh,
they do the DNA testing on it.
They're able to get a complete genome from it.
And what they discover is this isn't in the end Athol,
this isn't an anatomically modern human being.
This is another human species,
uh,
who they named the Denisovans.
They think they're more closely related to neanderthals than they are to
anatomically modern humans,
but they're clearly another human species.
And they also interbred with anatomically modern humans.
And Dennis Urban DNA survives,
interestingly enough,
it survives a predominantly in Australasia,
uh,
in Papua New Guinea and amongst Australian aborigines.
So as part of the research for this book,
I went to Dennis over cave.
I had an amazing,
actually just incredible trip to Russia.
I hadn't,
I hadn't expected it to be like that at all.
Siberia.
I mean,
America is vast,
but my God,
crossing Siberia,
this endless rolling plains,
you know,
this just vast area.
How did you cross it?
We took a car.
Uh,
w you can't travel independently in Russia.
It's very difficult.
You have to get,
you have to get permission and you have to state in advance where you're going
to be stopping off that.
So what I found,
and I just did,
so through the Internet was a,
was a local guy called Sergei Cogan,
um,
who had a little tour business,
in,
in Siberia,
in the city of novels,
CBS.
I got in touch with him.
He found a translator who would translate my emails and I said,
we want to make this journey to Dennis over cave,
uh,
and can you set this up for us and get the permissions?
And,
and he did.
And so we flew into novice,
a bisque.
Sergey and his translator who turned out to be a,
a Russian student who spoke good English,
joined us.
And we did this immense journey across Siberia.
Oh,
it took us three days to get to,
to get to Dennis.
Over k three days,
three days of driving every day.
Some stopping off along the way.
Incredible hospitality of the,
of,
of the Russians that we were.
We're amongst very independent people.
People are living out there and the wilderness and who actually do,
do know how to survive is the first time I've ever drunk milk.
Fresh from the cow,
literally milked right out of the cow and poured down my throat.
I was,
it was delicious.
And a cream,
I mean thick,
thick cream.
Very,
very,
so.
It was a lot of things about Russia that surprised me.
Dennis over caves.
A fascinating,
beautiful pace of visit.
It's another,
it's another example of a missing chapter in the human story that is beginning
to be pieced together.
It's obvious now that we were not alone,
that there were multiple other human species who are human enough to interbreed
with us and leave leave DNA.
And there's Dennis Obon species.
We've only discovered in like,
was it 2000 so I'm very recently the 2007 it's a very,
it's a very recent discovery and,
and it's a lot behind art.
Hmm.
Did they leave behind art better than that?
They left behind.
Um,
certain physical objects which are extremely hard to explain.
One of them is a greenstone bracelet,
uh,
and that bracelet is in the form of a talk which was therefore slipped on
sideways onto the hand.
It's not a full ring.
Um,
and a hole has been drilled through the bracelet and from that whole it's been
possible to reconstruct that appendant was hung then the archeologists,
there it is.
Then the archaeologists started to take a look in detail at the drill marks on
that hole and what they discovered was a huge anomaly that that was drilled with
a stable fixed drill and it was drilled at extremely high speed.
It's a,
this is thought to be 40 or 50,000 years old.
There is not supposed to have been any such technology in that period that was
capable of drilling with a stable,
fixed the drill.
And yet there it is and,
and,
and there it appears.
So there,
there are also incredible,
very fine needles,
bone needles that the Denisovans made very long ones,
which suggests that they were stitching very heavy stuff together in the
suggestion has been were they making skin boats for example,
to,
to use to navigate that would explain how they managed to get themselves to
Australia,
which is where the largest amount of Denisovan Dna,
uh,
so,
so survives today.
There's one of those,
there's one of those needles.
So th th th there are indications of strangely out of place technology amongst
the dentist servants,
which is 20,
30,000 years earlier in the human story than it then.
It should be those kinds of needles,
that kind of bracelet you could expect to find them in what archeologists call
the Neolithic.
But to find it in the Paleolithic is very puzzling and very audinate suggests
that the Denisovans were secondly,
not a sat shambling sub sub humans that they,
they were refined creatures.
Can you find out what year the discover the Denisovans Jamie,
can you Google that real quick?
I want to say it's in the two thousands but I mean,
imagine that human beings have been around for this long.
Here we are in 2019 and within the last decade or so they figured this out.
Yeah.
We are discovering new stuff about ourselves.
We're discovering the,
our story is much richer,
much more textured,
much more layered than we thought it was.
It's not a simple story.
It's a very complicated story.
And we ourselves are hybrid species.
We are,
we are the result of interactions with all kinds of different looking human
beings.
And the end,
the end result is ourselves.
So it's not just that we carry neanderthal or Denisovan DNA in a sense.
We are neanderthals and Denisovans uh,
you know,
and have their,
they are part of the anatomically modern human human heritage.
So you make a good point.
The fact that this is only being discovered now and that it's an incredibly
important,
I mean it,
it completely rewrites the story of our ancestry.
The notion,
the notion of 19 seven,
1970s.
Oh,
okay.
And where are the real work that's been done in Dennis over cave has been done
in the two thousands from,
from 2006,
2007 Altima.
That's when the major papers have been 2008 there had been published,
which have,
which have revealed the genome of the Denisovans and revealed the dentist
servant connection to two anatomically modern humans.
The fact that we're only finding this out now that we,
that we told the story of our past and weren't aware of this raises the
question,
how much else in the story of our past is there that we're not aware of?
Let's stop being so arrogant,
so sure of ourselves.
So confident in our findings that's be more tentative.
Let's keep an open mind and see and see where it takes us.
That's,
that's the main message that I have from,
from all of this.
And I think,
um,
and I hope that this will be an effect of this book.
I'm not,
I'm not kidding myself that the archeologists are going to jump on board,
uh,
overnight particularly.
So since I'm very critical of American archeology in this book,
and I'm critical of it specifically and explicitly because of the dominance of
the Clovis first model for so long,
which prevented at the research taking place.